ورطه محليه قد ترهق الاقتصاد الصيني اي
ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم وتتحول الى
فوضى طويل المدى فديون المحليه الصينيه
تقارب 23 تريليون دولار من ضمنها الاقتراض
الخفي لالاف شركات التمويل التي انشكتها
المقاطعات والمدن وفق وكاله الامريكيه
ورغم ان احتماليه تخلف الصين عن سداد
الديون المحليه المنخفضه نسبيا الى ان هذه
الديون تقلق المستثمرين بشكل متزايد وقد
تضطر الحكومات المحليه الى اجراء تخفيضات
انفاق مؤلمه خبراء اقتصاديون اكدوا ان
الحكومه المركزيه قادره على ابقاء الامور
مستقره على المدى القصير عبر مطالبه
البنوك بتمديد ديون المدن والمقاطعات
المحليه ولكن من دون تمديد للقروض ستعجز
اكثر من ثلثي المحليات على سداد ديونها في
الوقت المحدد ما يعرضها لقانونا فرض عام
2016 ينص على بدء اعاده الهيكله الماليه
اذا اعاده الهيكلة تشمل فرض بكين اجراءات
تقشفيه صارمه هذه الاجراءات اذا اذا ما
تحدثنا عنها منها خفض الاجور تاخير صرف
المرتبات تقليل الامتيازات الطبيه
للمواطنين وارتفاع اسعار الكهرباء والغاز
وزياده ايضا الغرامات الماليه بالنسبه لي
الصين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات